so
if i um if i recall correctly
the title that i i gave um for the talk
today
uh was about how to make your technology
uh
anti-racist um and i provided that
title uh number one because it's in line
with
um where i've been doing a lot of
thinking and
and where a lot of folks frankly have
been uh pushing me
quite a bit and so i'll step back for
just a second and talk a little bit
about the book black software which
michael mentioned which was an endeavor
for me that
was tremendously insightful
i should say by way of background i am
not
a technologist much of my career
has been focused on issues of race and
politics
in uh sort of the electoral
frameworks and context and so about 10
years or so ago i started to do
work in this area of race and
technology more uh more specifically
and that was motivated by a lot of
things it was motivated by
the fact that my primary interest around
race and equity and racial justice
in the political work and political
communication work that i was doing
started to really migrate into
online contexts more and more and so the
people that i was working with the folks
that i was interested in collaborating
with
uh were in online spaces were using
digital tools and so
over a period of time i started to
become much more interested in
what it was about the technology that
really fueled
uh some other aspects of collaboration
and community building that
uh folks i was working with were were
interested in
and then 2014 came uh and some of you
will be
familiar with uh the moment uh uh
where we saw uh the events of ferguson
missouri
uh saw the rise of black lives matter
movement
um and all of these new kinds of
movements with respect to racial justice
uh really getting on underway and
catapulting issues of racial justice
to the poor in the way that they hadn't
been
on the public agenda in the u.s context
for quite some time many many decades
in fact and so this got me really
interested again um curious about the
affordances of digital media technology
and its influence
in enabling black lives matter activists
to be able to do
and accomplish what it was that they
accomplished which i think was
hugely impactful um and
significant and so you know i remember
at the
um very beginnings of some of that
research and talking to
uh activists and these uh movements and
so forth who
um you know would push back often when i
would talk about the
sort of technological affordances that
really pushed and magnified their work
uh and folks who would really push back
to say look um
you know the work is the work and
technology is really something
off to the side and so they would resist
this notion of thinking about something
like black lives matter as a
digital movement or some aspect of what
we might call digital
activism and so i started to become
interested
more and more in uh simply this
juxtaposition
of race and racial justice and
technology and so that's where the
impetus for
the book black software came from
and when i started that book it was um
it was going to be a fairly short
book in that i thought i knew what it
was i was interested in writing about it
researching
and i had in my mind that
of course something like a black lives
matter and similar movements
don't emerge from nowhere particularly
those that are
impactful in the way that this uh this
was
um and so as i started to look for the
kind of digital footprints or
the technological origins of black lives
matter and similar types of racial
justice movements
i figured that story for me was going to
end
uh somewhere in the late or
mid 1990s sometime where we had the
origins of
the web as we as we know it
and what i began to discover and unravel
was a set of stories that really
pushed the limits of what i had come to
know about
the relationship between race and
particularly between
african americans and computing
technology
and in particular all of the literature
up to that
time as i had begun to research and
started to write
had said that the uh the relationship
between
race and civil rights in particular and
technology
um that these were sort of two parallel
stories
that they both as uh kind of new
revolutions in a way occupied
the same starting point in terms of
their origins
more or less but they were seen as two
parallel
um movements happening on very different
tracks with very little
interaction uh between the two and so
not much
on uh in the way of technology and uh
technologists and folks that were
influential or interacting with what was
going on in the civil rights movement at
the time in the
late 50s early 60s and beyond
and very few the other way uh around
civil rights activists and
uh leaders and so forth who were engaged
in
the growing uh technological enterprises
computing technology enterprises that
were
emerging at that period of time
and so the thing that i began to find
was that with my research and as i began
to talk with people in that
more recent history of the 2000s and the
90s and so forth
was that my timeline
started to get further and further and
further back in history
and doing so then pushed me
to unravel and to really uncover what i
thought was
at least for me a very different
and revolutionary uh story about the
relationship between race and computing
technology
that i had no prior knowledge of
but that struck me as very significant
when we think today about the
relationship between
race racial justice and technology
particularly for the prospect of
thinking about
how we might use technology to
bring about more equitable more just
more racially
just communities a world
etc and so as i've been talking about
uh the book to various audiences in
particular when i began to talk
a lot with computer scientists
folks uh in technical communities
technologists of one stripe or
another i always started to get this
question about all right if
our past is what it is and has been
how do we think about change how do we
think about the process
of doing things differently from the
standpoint
of both the imagination
of technology and new technological
tools to their design
to their uh build and to their
proliferation
out into um use in
in various environments so what uh
does anti-racist technology look like
and so
i had originally thought that that's
what i would talk about today and had
been
prepared to um to do so
to address that particular question
about how to make
technology anti-racist or how to think
about technology
in an anti-racist framework of course uh
requires us to think about some other
questions that um
pop up from time to time in conversation
uh that i find
are both um interesting on the one hand
uh for other folks it tends to be
a barrier in terms of really coming to
grips with
terminology or concepts when we try to
think about this relationship between
technology and race and racial justice
and so
can computing technology uh
be racist is often a question
particularly if we start from the
standpoint of how to make technology
anti-racist which presumes that
technology is racist and so can
computing technology
be racist whether we're talking about
software or hardware or
algorithms where we're talking about uh
digital platforms the internet
uh artificial intelligence uh various
forms of machine learning applications
all of these questions animate our
current
conversations both in a way that
tries to i think connect our history
our present and really in a lot of ways
our future in terms of the ways and the
influence that technology might have
uh on our ability to
create a world a society that we think
is uh much more just and
in line with what it is that we desire
so how to make your technology
anti-racist
and then these questions about uh can
computing technology
be racist and if so what does that look
like and so i decided that what i would
spend most of my time talking about
today is this
final um question about how our
computing technology became racist
because i think
that's where a lot of confusion comes
into play we all have varying
definitions about what racism is what
constitutes being
racist some of which i think is
productive some
not but often it becomes the thing we
have to push
through and confront to be able to get
to the other side of being able to think
about
anti-racist text so the next few minutes
that's what i want to focus on and talk
about a little bit of
what we might call an origin story of
racist technology or the anatomy of
racist technology or thinking about the
structure
of racist tech or technology
infrastructure as i uh often describe it
so let me see if i can
push the right button to get to my next
slide here there we go
so let me start with just a brief
definition
um and often this is where things
uh conversations on this topic sort of
go off the rails because people have
very
differing conceptions of and definitions
of what
racism uh is so for me racism has a
very specific um and somewhat narrow
set of definitions uh and that's seeing
in that sort of middle
section here that racism for me is
by definition always structural
it's systemic and because it is
structural and systemic it
is uh processes structures
systems that produce advantage and
disadvantage
along racial lines so that's my simple
way simplified
a definition of racism
these uh uh advantage and disadvantages
uh might accrue and the systems that
promote them
might do so either intentionally
and by design um and we'll talk about
some of
uh perhaps examples of that uh today
uh the other aspect and what you know i
think probably most often is the case
and
uh part of our experience today is that
uh we see these
in varying forms of disparate
outcomes and those different outcomes
being again aligned along
uh racial uh differences um
and so this is simply my framework for
thinking about racism
um and then informs what i think of
as uh racist technology or the answer to
the question can technology be
racist and if you haven't already um
uh figured out my answer that question
is
yes um and so i want to proceed in
telling you
uh sort of why i see it that way and i
wanna
take us through a story of um history um
and so i want to begin here there's a
lot in this slide and we'll
we'll spend a lot of time um here and
what i've tried to do
is both to piece together a story but
also a kind of
architecture if you will or structure
or the beginnings of what come to be
both
our technological infrastructure from
the early 1960s
and building up to our current day but
also then
its connection with uh this
singular area around race and uh
several of its manifestations
so let's begin um in
uh about 1965 um
and certainly there are some earlier
starting points that i could begin with
but i think this is a good one because
um it is focused on where i think
the origin point if we will the
beginnings
of how technologies
become racist begin and that to me
happens around and in connection to
problems and so i want to
think about for just a few minutes about
problems
and the problem that uh the us
as a country was focused on
in the early and mid 1960s
at the same time in which uh many other
things are going on
uh in this country particularly with
respect to
uh race and civil rights
and so in a little bit of a a
chronological order
here um in march of
1965 uh lyndon johnson then president
lyndon johnson
uh gave what was uh for many folks his
most
famous speech it was a speech primarily
about civil rights and he
made this particular statement where he
said
there is no negro problem there is no
southern problem there is no northern
problem
there is only an american problem and we
are met here tonight as americans
to solve that problem
so a couple of things i want to draw
your attention to which is on the one
hand
um johnson's speech here was really
about civil rights it was really about
looking
forward to a number of civil rights
legislation and initiatives that he was
hoping to
build support for and so from his
standing
uh his standpoint in this speech and
talking about
race and problems and talking about the
negro problem
as it were at that time was all in
line with what he saw as steps towards
more and greater civil rights
but within that i think it is um
imperative for us to point out that uh
that being what it was and is
still means that at that particular time
in the 1960s
the primary problem facing the country
the most important problem
on many people's minds in the public
arena
in the uh public sector in terms
of those in government and places of
policy and power was race
and particularly what was happening on
the streets across the nation which was
the outpouring of
protests and other forms of civil unrest
and civil disobedience that was playing
out
from uh black folks and uh
other allies who are fighting for civil
rights
so johnson makes this statement in um
in march of that year
earlier in that same time frame
uh part of johnson's constituency is
trying to convince him that
the primary problem that really faces
the country is
a question or a problem of crime
and long story short that these two
things uh our race problem or negro
problem and the crime problem
uh ends up being juxtaposed or
being essentially one and the same i
should say
um and so our crime problem which
johnson interestingly enough uh did not
think
was a problem of national magnitude
um as far as he uh
you know saw and was looking out on all
of the
um the imperatives of the time and the
priorities of the nation crime was not
at the top of his list but
many of his constituency and primarily
white constituency
he was pushing him to say look what's
going on
crime is rampant that crime problem was
often
focused uh in the usual places and with
the usual suspects in urban
ghettos in large cities that were
primarily occupied by black folks
and uh particularly those that were uh
poor but not exclusively so
and so in 1965 the summer of 1965
johnson um calls into being
the commission on crime and the
administration of justice
um so this is july of 1965 the latter
part of july that this task force
gets called into being and it has a very
wide mandate which is simply to
inquire into the causes of crime why do
people commit crime
and how can we go about as a nation best
solving the problem of crime and
ensuring that
people have no reason to and certainly
that there
is a a justifiable remedy to
those who do commit crime
and so again this comes into being in
july
about two weeks later uh we have
um what was probably one of the most
well-known and largest at the time
uh of these um uh
these protests in watts that erupted on
the streets of
south central los angeles in august
1965.
um this was in watts
a situation that came about much
like uh the things that we've been
saying on the streets of
this country over the last few weeks and
years which was a community that was
highly segregated that was primarily
black
and that had been battling for years
against treatment and brutality by
the lapd by police officers and the law
enforcement community in
los angeles uh that erupted uh that
uh day in august 1965. uh
national guard troops uh by the tens of
thousands were called in
at the end of the day 35 or 40
african-americans were uh killed were
dead
many thousands others were arrested and
jailed um and this became
probably the the most prominent visible
spectacle about the black
civil rights struggle that the nation
had begun to see
and what they saw and how they
interpreted it
in large part because of their own
perceptions but also because
of the media's framing of it at the time
they saw black lawlessness they saw
black criminality
uh run amok and on display in this
particular moment so
as the uh the president's commission
gets started
on their task of trying to understand
the so-called crime
problem we start to see a
crystallization
of what not only the public
but the law enforcement community and
those in uh public policy arenas
are starting to see as the face
of the nation's crime problem which was
black which was urban
which was largely poor and so this
becomes the problem that the nation
has to solve at this point in time in
1965.
the other part of this story and this is
interesting that
um i'm sure that uh this was always
going to be part of
the commission but certainly
gained new traction in the aftermath of
watts
when uh the commission uh
tasked uh its crown jewel
and so let me step back to say that the
crime commission was made
up of several uh task forces
each of which were directed to very
different sectors
of trying to understand and tackle the
crime problem and so you see those
listed here
some of those task forces that were
focused primarily on policing some on
the courts
juvenile juvenile justice organized
crime
and some particularly those in the
social and behavioral
sciences and so forth focusing on the
uh the determinants of crime and trying
to understand why
people get involved in crime in the
first place
but for johnson and for his attorney
general
nicholas katzenbach the science and
technology task force
was the crown jewel of
this commission and essentially
this is what uh gave this group
an imperative from johnson from
katzenbach
and it is seen in this comment uh here
um that ag that katzenbach makes
in the final report of the commission
but this was also
part of uh the sort of marching orders
for this task force
at the beginning and they laid out this
justification
saying that more than 200 000 scientists
and engineers are helping to solve
military problems
but only a handful are helping to
control the crime
uh or control the crimes that injure or
frighten millions of americans
each year and so essentially what
happens is johnson looks around and says
look we've seen and we are in in the
midst of this new
uh computing revolution a revolution
that has already
uh showed its value in uh in terms of
war
in terms of space and so
how can we mobilize this new
technological power to help us
solve our crime problem
again a crime problem that is very much
personified
in the faces and communities uh
primarily of african americans
and so here you know i wanna spend a
little bit more time trying to
sort of focus and emphasize that um
if we might say that there is a starting
point as it were
in terms of how technology becomes
racist then in my mind this is at least
an example of when
that happens that is when you have a
racialized problem and particularly a
racialized problem
for which the people themselves are
identified as
and framed as the problem that must be
solved
so when you have that problem that is
then juxtapo
juxtaposed uh with a technological
imperative that is a call for new
technology to help
solve a problem that is a problem
primarily about
human beings and done so in a way in
which
the problem and the people who personify
it
are objects in
this relationship not participants in
um a a relationship in which technology
is going to be
used to try to help ameliorate and
address
uh this particular problem and so in the
same way that
technologies that helped us on the
battlefield
places like watts and other places
across the u.s
that erupted in the same ways throughout
66 67 the period of time that this
commission is doing
its work was very much framed in the
same way
as a battlefield um primarily made up
of lawless people
who were black who were poor and who
needed to be solved
in some way who needed to be policed and
so the technology
task force in many ways was called
into being to help
address this problem to shed light on
new ideas
um and things that we could do forward
looking from that
point in time into the future to help
make sure that we
solve this crime problem
and so one thing i'll do before
continuing is simply
sort of identifying and i mentioned that
all of these columns on the left which
are the different task forces that made
up the commission
though these were independent task
forces what we
end up seeing though that though they
don't sort of
follow from the science and technology
task force as is sort of laid out here
all of the recommendations that end up
coming up in each of these separate task
forces
in some way end up funneling back
through the science and technology task
force
meaning that technology was the broadest
framework
for how it was the commission uh thought
about
uh this new national task and imperative
about trying to solve crime
that our greatest ability and our
greatest
power to be able to address and solve
this problem
was going to be through our technology
and so
not only were the recommendations of the
science and technology task force
uh which we'll see here in a second not
only did those play
a role but all the other recommendations
for each of these
other uh segments were filtered through
this prism of um how do we then
marshal computing technology to do or to
operationalize what has been recommended
in each of these
task forces
here we can see um we can just sort of
scroll through a bit and i'll give you a
second to just kind of look through
these were some of the
recommendations from the science and
technology task force
uh in particular um and it's interesting
that
that task force uh
in terms of its makeup and in terms of
what it was that they
uh did as a body it's interesting or at
least it was very interesting to me
that number one that you had sort of
three groups represented on that task
force
so you mostly had folks from the
scientific
compute community particularly from
the computing world and so
you had folks who were very much
technologists who were at the cutting
edge mathematicians
operations researchers uh folks that
were very much in the mindset of trying
to really
uh model um and sort of model behavior
in terms of crime and thinking about
computational
solutions in varying ways
and so you have technologists scientists
that are making up part of the body of
this
task force the others are also
less technologists but part of the the
private sector
and particularly in this case with um
with ibm
and interestingly ibm who made uh or who
was represented in a large way on this
task force both from a technological
standpoint as well as from a marketing
standpoint so several folks
on the science and technology task force
were
ibm marketing personnel
and again that goes back to this
uh this idea about problems and the
centrality of problems
and its connection to technology this
was one of the ways in which
of course ibm marketed itself at that
time which was
a company that solved
problems and that marshalled computing
technology to solve problems and so
their point of view was
does it matter if it's in criminal
justice or in banking or in logistics or
transportation
you give me your problem we will build
and customize
a technological solution for you
and so interesting to see that
represented
in the work of this committee that
largely
then uh did a number of experiments
simulations etc to not only try to
understand
um and come up with ideas for new
technologies that could help in this
space but to
give the uh the policy community to give
uh the president a model for what
could be or what could be a new
uh technological enterprise a new
technological infrastructure that could
help
undergird support and further the
mission of helping to address and solve
uh crime problems
um so hopefully you've been able to see
some of these on this list i won't point
some of them
out given that time is already uh
running uh
quickly uh but this gives you an idea of
some of the
computational solutions uh that were
uh and came out of this particular
task force the next step
in the process that i will point out is
the end result
of the task force which
many of the recommendations that were
made
both by the science and technology
community as well as or the task force
as well all those other
task forces that i mentioned
found their way in a new very large very
expansive
legislative package called the omnibus
crime control
and safe streets act of 1968.
um to put a long story short
if you think about modern policing today
if you think about our
technological infrastructure our social
and political infrastructure around law
enforcement and policing
all of its have all of it has its
origins
back to this very significant
legislation
that comes out of the task force in 1968
one of the
recommendations of course that came from
the science and technology task force
was that a new agency be
created that would essentially be
a massive research and development arm
of thinking about technology in the
service
of law enforcement and that was enacted
through what was called the law
enforcement
assistance administration that was
created through this legislation
in 1968 and what
this office did essentially was provide
the funding and other forms of support
to build new technological systems
in the service of law enforcement and so
you'll see a number of
projects that come up from uh very early
stages
um projects that were getting underway
some of which were
uh even coming to completion already by
1970 these come
through in the first report of the leaa
in 1970 so
project search for instance the system
uh for electronic electronic analysis of
retrieval of commun
criminal histories um project
trace a system that looked to optimize
um uh data to try to understand which
cases to
uh adjudicate at what time um
tactical police information systems
which was another massive
data system that would help
to both search criminal histories
across the u.s through increasingly
connected
databases as well as to be able to
um identify target and
bring information to the floor to the
law enforcement community
through these other identification
markers fingerprints
mug shots etc the maryland interagency
law enforcement
computer system uh
and then others tin pin etc these all
just give you a flavor of
what this new computational law
enforcement infrastructure was starting
to look like
which really focused a lot on data
collection being able to have places to
store data
being able to have the ability to uh
at one's fingers tip to retrieve
data about criminal acts about arrest
about
crimes that had been committed and the
people who
committed them and then increasingly
uh to not only have those independent
systems but then to
uh network those systems and so you
start to see
uh networking that's going on from these
uh systems sometimes they start with a
group of states
uh connected to something like a project
search
and then those states going from five
states to 15 to 20
and then a number of
and networks between these systems and
the
national uh criminal justice or criminal
justice database
by the fbi all of which provides the
uh the opportunity to link data
across the united states for the
retrieval
of uh criminal data about particular
perpetrators or suspects of
crime and i'm going to try to run
through this because i do want to leave
some time for questions here's just
another picture
of what begins to proliferate in 1968
and beyond and so this is the the first
report of what was called criminal
justice
information systems came to be called
these
systems looked different in some way but
all of which
focused on this data repository that was
used to advance a number of
police and law enforcement capabilities
and so this gives you a sense of where
these things were
popping up and they were across every
state in
the u.s as well as u.s territories
you can see that these were systems that
were focused on various
aspects of law enforcement from tracking
crimes and arrests
to reporting on
cases as they move through the courts
and corrections system
things that focus on behavioral aspects
of
prisons and jails and the prospects of
rehabilitation and then other aspects
of this this is a different view these
are all the variables
at the top of top row of that prior
slide and you can start to see a little
bit
more depth into what was being taken
into account
about the systems that were being
built on everything from their funding
and how much money they were getting
from
the law enforcement grants
from the new agency the contractors
who's going into service to help build
these systems
all the different companies like ibm or
other tech companies that are part of
doing this
and then you can start to see the
varying law enforcement uses
for these systems to track arrests
i've highlighted some of these in orange
to really talk about
the building capabilities that start to
be
possible with these new systems things
like crime trend analysis
uh thinking about criminal associates
where we start to get
the idea of um sort of dragnets criminal
dragnets
uh that are happening where we find
someone who has a history of crime and
then we go find
folks that are associated with that
person and then somehow bring them
into uh the criminal justice system
simply by association and not
necessarily
by particular actions
and then you can see over here in this
third column one of the more important
things
around simulation and modeling and then
what we get into
in terms of capabilities around
predictive policing
and profiling profiling
by race profiling by neighborhood
characteristics geography
all of the things that come into play
again
all of this is and has started to
proliferate
across the country in massive uh ways
and systems uh by 1970
um by the time you get to the end of the
70s
uh there are hundreds of these um and
they continue
to grow and grow
i'm gonna leave it there there's so much
to say and i've skipped over
so much but i want to be able to have
some discussion so that you're able to
sort of fill in
some of the the blanks but what i wanted
to really sort of point out
is again how might we say
a technology becomes racist and why do i
find it so
easy and matter of fact to say yes
technology can be racist and that
technology
at least in this respect in this sector
where we talk about
law enforcement technology is racist
and i think that one of the things i
wanted to sort of show
albeit um uh not in a very detailed
uh or perhaps even effective way here
is the way in which structure
systems etc work together
uh to build this edifice that then has
disparate outcomes along racial lines
and i thought i would sort of leave
aside
uh the outcomes because at least in the
world that i sit those seem so
um uh glaring and visible in terms of
the devastation
that law enforcement and computational
law enforcement i will put it that way
has devastated and impacted
communities of color uh african
african-american
communities in particular and when we
look today
at the many different forms of
law enforcement technologies from
predictive policing things like
stat and command and control systems
that are part of a growing number of
police forces across the
country saturation pro patrolling racial
profiling facial recognition
all of these things that we know have
had disparate and devastating
consequences on communities of color
all have a very specific
linear footprint towards
uh and to that origin story and origin
moments back in 1965
and 68 and so when i talk about um
technology as being racist
this is an example of what i am talking
about and then if we were to have a
discussion
about what does anti-racist technology
look like
for me that means in some part thinking
about what it would take to
undo something of what we have just seen
over the last
few minutes and whether that is a
complete
undoing of the structure and system or
the replacement of new technologies
uh in various aspects of this structure
that would have
uh more positive consequences on other
areas
of uh the system um
and so there's a lot uh there and i
think
at this point i'll just uh quit talking
uh because there's so much more to say
and i've talked too long and that you
have questions and i'm very
happy to hear them so thank you for your
attention
and i look forward to your questions and
comments
thank you charlton excellent so
we have uh a number of questions that
we've started to get
through the submission system i will try
to i will be the greek course here
panelists says as usual feel free to go
ahead and unmute yourselves
and just go ahead and ask the questions
directly charlton the
panelists are uh phd students and
faculty here and
um i'll i'll kick it off and then we'll
hand it off to the panelists
so we have a question for wondering how
your own personal perceptions around
racism and technology have changed due
to the pandemic
um has it given you any sort of new
perspectives or is it sort of
reinforcing what you what you were
already thinking what would have been
your your reactions
yeah that's a great question i mean i
think in a lot of ways it has
reinforced um my thinking um
uh you know i think you know it could
only be that way having come from
just uh writing and putting out this
book and so
in a lot of ways the pandemic sort of
magnified
um uh much of the current of what it is
that i was already
thinking particularly as we you know
started to look at you know of course
the
rush of uh sort of technological
solutions at the beginning of the
pandemic right
uh from various forms of hardware uh to
software
that would uh uh was sort of developing
to do everything from protect folks from
the virus and so ventilators and so
forth
uh to software to help track uh
transmissions and so forth
um and verizon of uh you know ai or
machine learning
uh that was developed in the service of
that
and you know and i recall in the moment
where
you know we had that sort of massive
realization about
uh what communities were being
disparately
impact by the virus itself uh but also
who and in what communities were the
proliferation of these new technologies
particularly
those that were so problematic in terms
of privacy and invasiveness and tracking
who those were focused on um and so many
folks of course
uh you know this was some surprise in
some way for me
it was really you know and a different
um sort of manifestation of what i would
already see and uh say and that's
i'll sum up in sort of this way which is
you know we often talk about
race and technology or racism and
technology
and thinking about anti-racism in terms
of
technological solutions and for me
in large part our solutions
aren't so much technological because the
problems
are really around race um
deeply um even before the technology and
so this racial
structure of inequity was already in
place
uh when the pandemic hits and so it was
natural
and expected for someone like me to see
the kinds
of ways in which that played out
thanks charlton uh over to the panelists
yeah if i might jump in thank you so
much charlton that was a great talk
i'm a phd candidate in the group i do
work on
marginalized people's experiences and
representation in socio-technical
systems and so i was really excited to
hear this work
and i'm really excited for the book uh
the thing that i wanted to ask you was
kind of similarly along the lines you
were just touching on to what extent do
you think
the uh the racism that has resulted from
these systems or the racism that they
contribute to
is you know due to the technology and
like is there such a thing as like
better technology that would help avoid
those outcomes
or is it really that you know the
structure of policing and law
enforcement
was from its inception racist and
therefore any technology that was sort
of aiding towards that end was going to
end up kind of
following in those kinds of footsteps
and maybe exacerbating or continuing
those problems
so is it possible even really to
separate those two do you think that the
the issues kind of stem from the
fundamental structure of
law enforcement policing uh you know
into what what degree is
the technology kind of adding or or
doing more on top of that
yeah great question and i you know i
lean towards
the latter right and it's um it's the
reason i define
um sort of racism and uh sort of racist
tech in the way that i do which is
when you have a structure and system
that is already
targeted and built in infrastructure to
do certain things
um then any new thing
tends to go in the service of that ideal
regardless of sort of the intent of
the new thing right and so this is why
i think there's so much of um inertia
and why things don't change because of
course you have
technologists who you know who don't
want to do those things and are building
new systems
but then what else is going to happen
when you build a
law enforcement technology that comes
with it
already a sense of what the imperative
is
what its use is where it needs to be
deployed who is going to even support
the infrastructure for its development
and uh proliferation and all those
things
exist before the the sort of
technological
um new and so uh
so i that's very much how i think about
things it's
um you know it tends towards the
pessimistic side which i have to admit i
i
stay in most of the time um
when we get to the question about how do
we undo
and part of why i've started to talk a
lot about anti-racist technology is
really to
guard against the idea that this could
be
simple and simplified in the ways that
we've talked about let's say
um you know uh ameliorating bias
in technological systems where you know
the thought is if we could just make a
better system better
algorithm better inputs better data
things will be better and i think
probably not and so a much more
wholesale
change of system but you know to the
optimistic side i do think
is possible and part of the reason why i
like talking about this kind of origin
story is to show
that these things have beginnings
right and if the current infrastructure
had a beginning
it also means something different could
have a
beginning absolutely thank you so much
absolutely thank you i'll pop to a
question from
someone who's in a who's a student or an
attendee
asking how do we integrate communities
of color into the design process to
ensure that the tech is anti-racist
without asking them to do
a ton of labor
that's a great question and i think um
i think the reality the short answer is
we can't
um it is labor on both parts
and so i don't think that we should
think about how do we not
um sort of get away or ask folks to do
that labor i think it's about how do we
make sure that that labor
is rewarded and valued and really
accrues value to
those communities and so
you know i think the large part of the
story that i didn't tell here
had a lot to do with um not so much who
was involved but who wasn't
and i think that's part of what this
question goes to that is
if black communities had been part of in
1965 and 68
this let's think about what solutions
could be
and what could we and how could we
marshal
this new computing capability to
um uh to help think about these the
problems of
of that day i think we may have had
quite different outcomes but in 1965 we
didn't have the inclination to do so
nor um uh the the structure
to do so now today when we uh do have
the inclination which i think
is a great step forward
i think we find ourselves without a
structure that
enables us to do so and do so
at a scale that is meaningful
so so i i don't have a question or an
answer to this question because i think
um we have yet to really grapple with it
i think we recognize that it is a
problem
but we need scaffolding we need an
infrastructure that says here are groups
of
technologists or varying groups of
people that are
embedded in a community who is
a position to think about the knowledge
that comes from those communities
as being valuable to give time to
engender trust in that community
to make sure that there is not just sort
of this extraction
uh going on but uh that there is uh
value um accruing uh to that
and i think we simply don't have the
structures to
enable that we don't have that structure
in the university
we don't have that structure very well
in government that helps to do so so
that is one thing that i think
we have to we have to build and again i
think that was something that was
crystal
clear and sort of magnified in
coven where folks saw
communities that were being disserved
and
disadvantaged and yet no real way
to move at a deliberate speed take into
account
who those communities were and what it
is that their needs and privileges
or priorities were and our
varying technological systems or other
systems for helping to ameliorate
problems so i think uh you know a
particularly great work to be done to
figure out
how to build an infrastructure for this
to
uh to happen i'm wondering
uh really quickly because you focused a
lot on on structural
change being necessary to deal with a
lot of these problems
what can individual technologists do and
sort of what what do we gain
by giving individual technologists more
understanding of where their own work
falls in this sort of history
yeah thank you for that question because
you know oftentimes
um sort of my pessimism or the focus on
the enormity of structure
has that effect of sort of you know
paralyzing
folks right all right this thing seems
to be so giant
so what can i as an individual
technologist really do that will will
matter
and i think there is a lot to be done i
think that
i think what it does is to help give
individual technologists
a sense of what what could be and what
should be and so really to think about
their um
you know individual designs or what
they're imagining
um in a much greater
scope and scale because of the sort of
the necessity
of what needs to be there so if anything
i think it's
trying to open up for technologists a a
way to think about
all right here is something a
technological application that i want to
build
that may have limited utility or might
be
focused particularly in one small sector
of you know one of your colleagues i
talked to earlier who was working on
building collaboration systems so maybe
i build something that helps us
collaborate better and to do so in a
much more inclusive way and perhaps
even build something that helps
communicate
communities of color or other concerns
collaborate in that process of building
some of these new
technologies
so to be able to take something from
there and for someone to say all right
i can have this limited application and
i can sell it as a
app or something like that and some
people will use it and it will have some
limited
impact um but what could it be
if i have in mind over here a whole
system that i know a little bit about
um does this one little thing that i've
built
um have a point of connection with
another technology
in a different area or um
if i sort of connect this technology
with another
in a particular area could that give
greater impact and so
so trying to help folks get a sense of
what that broader system is in part to
get a sense of
what scaling looks like and what
uh impact could look like for folks that
are trying to build and are really
thoughtfully building
from an anti-racist perspective um
and i guess part of what i'm trying to
push against
is this sort of like you know let a
thousand flowers bloom which is quite
fine uh but often those thousand flowers
don't work
in concert with each other and so at the
end of the day
uh their impact is gone and we you know
we
smell them for a few minutes and then it
goes away
and we don't really get the value the
full value of that
and so i think understanding this
history
understanding the architecture of
a racialized systems can help
technologies think about uh
technologists think about what they're
designing and building
um in terms of how it might be more
impactful thank you
all right let's thank our speaker one
more time thank you so much for joining
us
um i will note that there were a number
of other questions there was
certainly a question that i saw several
various versions of you know we
continued the allies at the societal
level wondering about what to do as
individual technologists certainly a
thing that
i think a number of folks in the in the
group have been have been wrestling with
so thank you so much for spending
your friday afternoon with us now your
friday evening uh
have a wonderful and restful weekend and
i think we will end it here